um
the first photo they want to take with
the tablet for you okay
star photographer there yes
and here we go
okay you guys decide to everybody Global
policy agenda in a tough time
thank you very much
okay uh thanks everybody
and warm welcome good morning to
everyone and to these annual meetings uh
this is as usual our opening uh press
conference for the meetings and I think
you've all been watching what has been
happening the last few days we've been
releasing our Flagship documents the
world economic Outlook and so on and
with more to come over the next few days
uh starting right now and as the
managing director just uh pointed to we
have our Global policy agenda which I
think you've all received and we'll be
talking a bit about that later today so
with that
thanks to all of you for coming this
morning it's so great after three years
to see uh colleagues in the room
and of course we do have colleagues
online as well and we will take we'll
try and take their questions too with
that I want to turn to the managing
director Christina grigueva who will
make some opening remarks and then we'll
try and take as many of your questions
as we possibly can crystallina thank you
very much Jerry very good morning to
everybody in the room and whatever is
the time where you are so good to have
you virtually at this press conference I
cannot hide the joy I experience by
being with you in this room in person
again but I also cannot
hide the fact that this Joy is
overshadowed by the difficult
global environment by the fact that we
have a world economy that has been hit
by one shock after another
an unrelented pandemic
Russia's invasion of Ukraine
climate disasters on all continents and
now a cost of living crisis
the immediate toll on the global economy
is clear
you saw on Tuesday the IMF cutting our
growth forecast for 2023 to 2.7 percent
across many economies recession risks
are rising
and even when growth remains positive
for hundreds of millions of people it
would feel like recession because of
rising prices and shrinking incomes
and on top of it risks to financial
stability are also growing
uncertainty remains exceptionally High
the world economic Outlook
shows a one in four chance in other
words 25 chance that Global growth could
drop to a historic low of two percent
next year
this repeated shocks we have experienced
the growths setbacks they raise a bigger
question
are we experiencing a fundamental shift
in the world economy
from relative predictability and
stability
to Greater uncertainty and volatility
and what does it meet for mean for
policy makers
clearly a much more complex time
and that requires steady hence
on the policy levers and this is what
our Global policy agenda we released
today calls for
the price of policy misstep
the price of poor communication of
policy intentions
is very high
this week we have an opportunity
to work towards
minimizing the risks of missteps and
poor communication
let me give you a few highlights
in this context of us appealing to
policy makers
to act with the sense of
urgency now and also to act together
we see very clear areas where we can do
better
even in this more complex environment
first
bring inflation down
we know that Rising interest rates come
at some cost to growth but we also know
that not tightening enough
to put the leash on inflation
would mean interest rates
staying higher for longer resulting in
even more harm to growth and to people
for central banks this means taking
decisive action when it is necessary but
also it means communicating as clearly
as they can
second
act now to put in place responsible
fiscal policy
we must prioritize protecting the
vulnerable the vulnerable households the
vulnerable businesses that are
so important for the economy to function
but we have to do that with a fiscal
buffers exhausted because of the
pandemic levels of that very high and so
the the obvious conclusion is that
policy measures need to be well targeted
and they need to be temporary
steer away from across the board fiscal
support
that is neither effective nor affordable
if we are to help
people and fight inflation we must
ensure that fiscal and monetary policy
go hand in hand
you heard me
saying that multiple times I'm going to
say it again because it is so important
for this message
to penetrate when monetary policy puts a
foot on the brakes
fiscal policy should not step on the
accelerator because if it does we are
for a very dangerous right
and third we need to act now to
safeguard Financial stability
particularly as we see Rising financial
sector risks macro Prudential policies
need to be even more Vigilant and
address proactively pockets of
vulnerability
in this environment we also must support
vulnerable emerging market and
developing countries it is tough for
everybody but it is even tougher for
countries that are now being hit by a
stronger dollar High borrowing costs
capital outflows a triple blow that is
particularly heavy for countries that
are on the high level of debt
so
zeroing in on that and this is already
already happening this week
especially for low-income countries
where over 60 percent are at or near
that distress is Paramount
and we need stronger efforts to confront
food insecurity
345 million people are acutely food
insecure what it means is that their
children and women and men are at risk
of dying
because of hunger
we are taking also a look into the
future the future is not gonna wait we
need
transformational reforms to address
climate change change to make Digi
digitalization work for people in the
economy and to address inequality
so we have to do it not only acting with
sense of urgency now we have to do it
acting together
we are working with our 190 members on
many of these issues
our economic analysis is front and
center to help countries navigate this
complex environment and avoid policy
mistakes our lending is aligned with our
contraceyclical role
since the pandemic became we began we
provided financial support to 93
countries some 260 billion dollars since
the Russian invasion in February we have
supported 18 new programs uh these are
new programs and augmentation of
existing programs with close to 90
billion dollars and we now have
additional 28 requests
for support from the from the the fund
and that comes on top of the 650 billion
dollars SDR allocation uh you are aware
that we have an ambition of 100 billion
dollars
on lending of sdrs for countries in
strong position uh I'm sure those of you
who followed the topic want to know
where are we we are 80 to Target we have
just across over 80 billion uh dollars
uh and uh we are absolutely determined
to reach the target uh in the next month
we have created our first ever long term
financing instrument
to support the transformation of
economies the resilience and
sustainability trust it is now
operational
we have pledges of 40 billion and we
have staff level agreements for the
first three countries crossing the
Finish Line uh Barbados Costa Rica and
Rwanda and for countries suffering from
the food crisis we have
expeditionally expeditiously opened up a
window in emergency financing the food
shock window to provide rapid financing
to
Urgent needs and let me say finally a
word on on that
we are pressing for a more effective
debt resolution mechanism
we want the common framework to become
more predictable
with guidelines
and able to bring
equality of treatment for all creditors
public and private and we are also
looking for ways in which we can expand
that kind of donor coordination
to middle-income countries such as Sri
Lanka
so a lot to do during this week
uh and it is so important that we do
demonstrate
we understand the urgency to act and we
understand that acting together
makes a difference to the lives of
hundreds of millions of people thank you
very much for being here this morning
and Jerry the floor is back to you thank
you very much Christina we will release
uh crystallina's remarks uh pretty much
in real time so that helps you to follow
them and can I ask everyone to be very
succinct very short we'll try and be the
same and we'll try and take as many
questions as we can let's start with
Reuters David Lauder
David can you put up your hand so they
can find you thank you yeah
hi thank you uh manager director
um great to be here in person especially
for Jerry's uh final set of meetings
um I'm just wondering you've laid out a
whole lot of risks that you're dealing a
lot of risks a lot of challenges
um first and foremost among them you
seem to be indicating that inflation is
the top priority that the number one
thing to do do you think that can
realistically Be Tamed uh while this war
in Ukraine is still going on which has
created so many shocks uh so much
increase in energy and food prices which
are driving the inflation
um do we need to have the war end before
we can really tame inflation thank you
David I want to thank you for
recognizing Jerry
to those of you who have known Jerry for
many years you can only
imagine how my heart is bleeding that
that we are going to see him
taking a new part in life and I know we
don't do this at press conferences but
give this guy a big round of applause
it's fantastic
um
honest approachable
and all dedicated
to transparency to accountability to the
public this is Mr Jerry Rice okay to
your question uh I I do believe that
there is a lot that can be done to tame
inflation uh using the monetary policy
tools
why do I think so because we know that
during the pandemic there has been built
up of demand
and we see in the United States in other
places labor markets being very tight
and at the same time we have two sources
of demand of supply
interruptions uh the
interruptions caused by covet and those
caused by the push-up of oil and gas
prices now in any case when you have a
Slowdown of the economy that would mean
that also commodity prices would be
impacted and therefore there would be
independent on whether the war war goes
on or not we can see a positive impact
on inflation by by tightening up
Financial conditions
I do want to recognize that we need to
to very carefully
study the inflation phenomenon
in this
new world we find ourselves uh today
why because fragmentation in the world
economy
also means that we might see
shifts in Supply chains that impact cost
structures on a more permanent basis
and that is not what monetary policy can
address
but David there is plenty monetary
policy can and must address because of
this mismatch between uh demand and
Supply that is also due to Demand Being
uh still quite uh heated
I am
convinced that if we do not restore
price stability
we will undermine prospects for growth
we would create more uncertainty for
investors and we would put consumers in
a very difficult spot you all know
inflation is a tax
on the lower income parts of our society
and therefore cannot be allowed to
fester for longer but but you do put an
important question we do need to look
into what may be a longer term impacts
of shifts in in Supply chains on overall
level of price and this is another
reason why we're so Keen to bring the
world together and keep the world
together because if we lose the benefits
of a more integrated global economy we
all would be poorer and the impact would
be felt most dramatically in emerging
markets and developing countries
thank you crystallino as usual trying to
do a tour of the world as quickly as we
can so keep it short if you can please
shabbatai from devex right here in the
front row
uh thank you very much for taking my
question
um given the Outlook and all the risks
that you've highlighted and particularly
the fight against inflation which could
cause some slowdowns
um for emerging markets in particular
what's your prognosis for the most
vulnerable uh particularly if uh
overseas aid is not increased and if the
war in Ukraine carries on basically how
much more longer can these vulnerable
countries hang on yeah
we we let me start with the most
a dramatic of shocks
vulnerable countries are experiencing
and it is the foot shock we have
identified 48 countries that are
particularly severely impacted
by foot insecurity you wouldn't be
surprised that quite a large number of
them are in sub-Saharan Africa
a region of the world that is most
profoundly impacted by foot in security
at any at any time
uh we have been engaging with countries
and
mobilizing support not just from the
fund but from the International
Community working together with the
World Bank
with the world food program with the FAO
with the World Trade Organization
because we need not one set of measures
we need comprehensive set of measures
to address this particular vulnerability
the second big vulnerability for these
countries is that
and there what we are appealing for is
to make the common framework
more attractive we have now some modest
success with with Zambia and chat
but we don't yet see other countries
knocking on the door of the common
framework
why because the process is not very
predictable
it's like you're entering katano you
don't know where the other side of the
tunnel is
uh because the
way we bring all uh creditors is
lumpy you have the official creditors on
my side then you have the private sector
creditors so we have to expeditiously
draw lessons from uh Zambia and chat
what has worked and how and then applied
uh to countries to get that response to
that that insecurity
um to to to that being not not
sustainable to get response much more uh
actively and I do hope during the
meetings uh there would be a huge
attention paid and rightly sold to this
uh topic thank you Crystal you know let
me recognize uh Kobe Smithy Financial
Times Kobe can you raise your hand thank
you
thank you so much for doing this Colby
Smith with the financial times in light
of the vast uncertainty about the
Outlook and all the warnings about the
global economy and financial stability
risks I'm wondering if you worry that
the FED risks breaking something perhaps
by continuing with this very rapid 75
basis point pace and if that's something
it should reconsider and second to that
if you are concerned that central banks
are going to need to intervene like the
bank of England in order to shore up
Financial stability even as they press
ahead with interest rate increases
uh to to your first question
um uh it was uh very uh
telling and encouraging to listen to uh
secretary Yellen yesterday uh she
recognizes the uh
potential
impact of
policies in the United States for the
rest of the world and that is also the
position that the Fed chair Jay power is
taking that the FED needs to be mindful
of the impact it might have this being
said we all recognize that central banks
mandate is price stability at home
and they have to pursue this mandate
because uh think of the uh the uh
scenario in which inflation in the
United States doesn't get in under
control for a long period of time but
for the U.S but it also has spillover
impacts for the rest of the world uh how
can the U.S be mindful of uh impact of
course first by communicating very
clearly what are the intentions and
forming these intentions in a in a
thoughtful manner as they have been
doing and second U.S has other
instruments
to support countries and I think that
they have been quite prudent for example
the FED is using swap lines very
actively to help other countries and U.S
has been very focused on food Security
on on supporting also us the IMF the
World Bank in providing extending
support to other countries but I want to
be to be clear the reason we are
endorsing a strong focus on inflation is
because inflation has been quite
stubborn and the risk of inflation
expectations
de-anchoring has become
more uh visible
we cannot we cannot possibly allow
inflation to become a runaway train bad
for growth and bad for people but as bad
especially for poor poor people for poor
people
thank you Christina let me let's go to
Africa Simon in the front here Simon
atteva Africa today
yes
thank you for taking my question glad to
see you also Gary at your last press
conference and glad to see you miss God
Giver in person after three years and
especially after
some people try to distract you and read
that false story
but that's the pastor in recent days you
have repeatedly spoken about a darkening
economic Outlook and one against a
deepening food crisis in Africa
exacerbated by the war in Ukraine I
would like you to talk a little bit in
details about the situation in
sub-Saharan Africa where are we now what
specific policy recommendation do you
have for for do you have for Africa and
how should lenders and financial
institutions such as the IMF respond and
how darkening is the overall situation
in Africa and if you can touch a little
bit about the situation in the Horn of
Africa where we have the biggest
humanitarian crisis in Ethiopia right
now thank you
thank you very much for asking this
question
because
of all regions in the world
Africa finds itself
in the most precarious position why
because
Africa
was
already affected by footing insecurity
due to climate events
we sometimes forget that the Horn of
Africa and the Sahel were experiencing
food insecurity and for Somalia there
was already concerned that may become
very dramatic before the war in uh
Ukraine
we also know that
Africa
is uh
unfortunately
where we were as a global Community a
bit slow to provide the necessary
vaccination support to fight covet and
as a result we have the scarring from
covet in many countries more severe just
think what it means
for children
that are out of school
for two years
to then try to resume
classes many drop out especially girls
and that can have implications for quite
some time
but there are positive stories we can
tell many countries in Africa over the
last decade have built strong
fundamentals they have worked very hard
to increase their tax to GDP ratio so
they have the financial capacity to
support the economies and their people
and now they are faced with the need of
the International Community to stand by
them so what is Our advice to Africa
first do stick to a prudent
macroeconomic policies what we have seen
in the covet crisis countries that had
strong fundamentals like people with
strong immune systems they withstood the
shock much better than others
second for
this moment in a time if you are seeing
problems on the dead side act early and
as I said 60 percent of countries are in
the in or near that distress do not
hesitate do not wait third use the
support system that the multilateral
banks in the IMF is providing uh for you
and there we are mobilizing very firmly
as I mentioned the foot shock window but
we are also moving in many countries
with upper credit trench programs I met
with a number of presidents and finance
ministers from Africa to say let's work
together
to come out of this tough time with even
stronger position and above all it is so
important that Africa doesn't waver from
the the big big big policy decisions
like the Continental trade agreement to
implement them because there is so much
Africa can do for Africa just by making
it removing obstacles to uh to growth on
the basis of African integration my my
uh my Mantra has always been what is the
strength of Africa young population
how can you make use of the strength
invest in young people invest in digital
connectivity investing competitiveness
for for the future
let's go to the Middle East lady in the
front row
I mean the national
um the Middle East of course has a mixed
picture but you're speaking about the
threat of runaway inflation which we see
in Lebanon and it seems that hardly any
monetary policy can deal with the
devastating impact of inflation at 200
percent and more and yet we worry about
a vacuum and political power and the IMF
has been very clear on its conditions my
first is my first question about Lebanon
is what can we do given the
circumstances there
um and how the IMF sees the threat of
this political instability but more
importantly also this week we've heard
of the possibility of this deal between
Lebanon and Israel Maritime borders and
possibly some light for the energy
crisis and also the economic crisis what
impact can that have for Lebanon in the
region thank you
thank you and let's uh
let's celebrate when there is something
to celebrate and this agreement is a
reason to celebrate but it would only
materialize as a source of growth and
opportunities for Lebanon if we are to
have a
clear commitment
on a political level to work for the
stability of Lebanon and I would appeal
to everybody who is in the high
corridors of power in Lebanon to put
your country your people first
we have a staff level agreement
we cannot move why because the prior
actions we have identified that are for
the for the benefit of the Lebanese
people and not yet met there is still
this paralysis
and it can only be resolved by the
uh political leaders in Lebanon
putting aside what divides them and
getting to a point of serving the people
of Lebanon who deserve no less
thank you Christine let's turn to the
the UK I see Larry Elliot I see very
many maybe we'll take two from the UK
Larry you're you're up first
thank you not really I took the guardian
there were reports coming out of London
that the chancellor is planning to ax
some of the measures that he announced
on September the 23rd do you think that
would help calm financial markets and
remove some of the financial stability
risks that you talked about in your
opening remarks
so thanks Larry let's take one more from
the UK in the front Robin yes sir
um uh thank you Mark Stone from from Sky
News you said um in your opening remarks
that a complex time requires steady
hands on the policy levers so my
question simply is do you think the
British government's hands are steady
okay and let's just take one more lady
in the front
and then when they were gone from the UK
additional do you think the Prime
Minister will have to reverse additional
tax cuts to calm the markets down
uh let me start by by
sharing with you I had a very
constructive meeting with the chancellor
and the governor of Bank of England and
we discussed the importance of uh policy
coherence and communicating clearly so
there can be
no in this jittery environment there
could be no no reasons for more Jitter
to the people to those who are here from
the UK
um you have a country with strong
institutions and strong traditions of
transparent
evidence-based policy making and it is
the
Foundation of these institutions
of course the Independent Bank of
England the office for Budget
responsibility the engagement of the
parliament the public you from the press
that gives the reputation of the UK of a
country with a strength in in economic
policy making
our our message to everybody not not
just to the UK to everybody's at this
time
fiscal policy should not undermine
monetary policy because if it does it
then the task of monetary policy becomes
only harder and it translates into the
necessity for even further increase of
rates and tightening Financial
conditions
so don't prolong the pain
make sure that actions are coherent and
consistent and I do believe that
it is correct to be led by evidence so
if the evidence is that there has to be
a recalibration it is right for
governments to do so
thank you very much and and the bank of
England Larry the bank of England action
was appropriate there was a Financial
Risk to to financial stability the bank
of England addressed it
notwithstanding the commitment it has to
pursuing its main monetary policy
objective which is price stability
thank you very much Kristen let's keep
going around the world uh Argentina
Raphael plays in the front row
thank you very much jarian I want
farewell to you on your last annual
meetings about this morning Argentina
has passed two reviews on its uh IMF
program but inflation has gone up growth
is going down political risks remain
very high and the economy still very
fragile according to the IMF staff what
do you think is the best case scenario
argentines can hope for going forward
with this program and DMF has been very
accommodating to Argentina's requires
how flexible do you think the IMF is
willing to be in order to keep this
program afloat thanks our commitment is
to the people of Argentina
and what they expect is that their
government will take to heart the need
to
bring inflation down
to provide a platform for growth to
accelerate and that is what we support
with with our program
we are
fully mindful that not just in Argentina
in many countries
there is a
pressure from the public
that goes in the opposite direction of
what is best
for people
pressure to increase spending when it is
not affordable and that it and when it
fuels inflation and what we are very
pleased to see is that Minister Massa
has taken his responsibility
very seriously and his commitment his
team his himself to to stick to what we
have agreed in our program is uh
demonstrably there because we have been
able to complete successfully the second
review uh we will be very closely
following
how the economy responds to policy
measures we never take a program to be
uh you know set in stone if conditions
significantly change but I can tell you
that we are not going to be flexible
against the interests of the people of
Argentina we would be looking at the at
the reality scene Argentina
making sure that our program helps helps
to Anchor the economy and over time
bring the access to Market back to life
for Argentina your right to flag their
political
factors that exist in all countries
so
obviously we will be following very
closely how they may be projecting over
time and acting accordingly
thanks Christina let's turn to Asia I'm
going to go to colleagues online just
for a second Gabrielle Ian from CCTV do
you want to come in Gabriel then I'll go
to La Liga for India so let's take those
two questions and Gabrielle can you come
in
yes of course thank you Jerry thank you
very much director and Jerry for the
record I was clapping with managing
director and everyone else in the room
for you
um thank you for all of your help and
your work and um my question is on the
sustainable transition or the
environmental crisis that every country
is facing at right now given all of the
challenges that you've listed and most
of those challenges are more immediate
than the environmental challenge how do
you think or how would you advise
countries to still focus and invest on
sustainable transition right now thank
you
uh the uh very good question the
risk of course is there this year
possibly next year
that we would see more reliance
on fossil fuels
because of the energy
crisis that Russia's wore in Ukraine has
created
but I'm convinced that it would be since
we had our Argentine colleague before
you I would use an Argentine analog it
would be Tango but played the right way
we make one step backwards and then two
step steps forwards I am convinced that
what is happening today would only
accelerate the green transition because
energy security is now an added factor
in considerations of what directions uh
economies take
okay thank you very much crystallina
let's go to La Liga India
thank you Gary uh we'll all miss you
here Madam uh managing director I would
like to ask you about India which many
of your colleagues in the IMF have
described it as a bright spot in the
current Global scenario and your
expectations from India next year when
it hits the G20 G20 group what India
should do next year to lead this group
uh
India deserves
to be called a bright spot on this
otherwise darker Horizon because it has
been a fast-growing economy even during
this difficult times but most
importantly this growth is underpinned
by structural reforms
among them the remarkable success in
digitalization in India from digital ID
to providing all services and and
support
on the basis of access digital access
this has been indeed a huge factor for
India's success and the country is now
stepping into
taking the lead on G20 from that
position of strength which makes me
strongly believe that we would see
India leaving a mark on the world for
years to come during it during next
year's presidency and what could that
Mark be in what areas it could be in the
area of digitally digitalization
including digital money we know that we
need regulation of crypto we know that
we need to get some more attention to
cross-border payments and how we are
proposing uh public investment in the
infrastructure of a
cross-border payment platform
it can be in the area of bringing
more fairness in our institutions next
year we need to complete the 16th
quarter review India has been a very
strong voice for the fund to be
financially strong and also to be a
strong institution on the basis of fair
representation of our members it could
be in renewable energy what is not so
well known you know it that India has
really
leapfrocked in terms of solar and other
forms of renewable energy so I very much
look forward to to next year and I'm
sure that
it would make the people of India the
whole one point nearly 1.4 billion of
them are very proud thank you Chrisley I
want to take a question from China on
WebEx why are hey from the ukai global
and we'll try and squeeze in just two
quick ones we're running a bit over if
you can make it very short please
wire here please come in
thank you um so I had a question on uh
the global economy um as fat and other
major central banks continue to push
forward tightening policies in a
possible currency crisis on the way what
is the probability of the global economy
falling into recession next year thank
you Christina let us take one more Eric
Martin Bloomberg
yes thank you thank you very much
managing director I wanted to ask you
about uh the the imf's outstanding
credit and uh lending uh across the
board uh from our calculation is at a a
new record this year and I want to ask
you about IMF resources you just made a
reference to the quota review how
necessary is it to uh to get that review
done do you anticipate obstacles and um
you know we're in Washington a city
where everything always happens at the
last minute uh what expectation do you
have or hope do you have to get it done
prior to the December 2023 deadline in
other words in the course or earlier
next year perhaps thank you thank you
Eric and just one more last question is
going to come from AFP here in the front
row
AFP
and we can make it shorter and there is
somebody that is saying me too please
yeah one more another press conference
tomorrow sorry um so be from the AFP
um so G20 representatives are meeting
today and you've previously called for
decisive action led by the group as the
world faces multiple shocks so we wanted
to ask with divisions within the G20 and
a lack of consensus on Ukraine um are
you worried that tensions could derail
some of the progress on issues that were
discussed this week such as inflation
and poverty thank you
sorry Crystal yeah this is it okay
probability of recession has gone up
we estimate that
two-thirds of the world economy
equivalent
will experience two
or more consecutive quarters of negative
growth
and as I mentioned in my opening
we think that
the risk of global recession is now
25 percent so it is not negligible
but we still have
uh
in our hands instruments that can
navigate through it is a narrow path but
the part is there and it is like you
know climbing uh Mountain if we hold
hands we follow each other steps we
actually can get there we can avoid a
global recession
on the IMF resources uh Eric we still
have
slightly over 700 billion dollars
available to to land you're you're
absolutely right demand for fund
financing has increased this is very
logical when growth prospects go down
when recession risks go up we do need to
step into our country code role
proactively and I do encourage our
members not to hesitate if you think
that you need a buffer we are here for
you and that particularly applies to the
innocent bystanders countries with
strong fundamentals hit by exogenous
shocks we have precautionary lending
facilities for you so we are far from
from from being constrained as as you
also know we have come up with this
innovation of on lending sdrs we are
targeting 100 billion this is additional
additional to our Landing capacity of
one trillion and uh uh should there be a
need we may appeal to our members to do
even more now the average is around 20
percent of the sdr's a strong economies
received uh France set up a good example
saying we are going to go to 30 let's
see how the economy shapes up do we need
to do more uh you're you're right to say
that usually these decisions are taken
uh after a great deal of negotiations in
the last moment we have a deadline
mid-December 2023
there is a possibility that we may see
some acceleration why because of the
complicated uh global economic
environment then maybe they may be
desire to send the signal that the fund
is there for the members and since as I
mentioned in an answer to to a question
about India since India is the next
chair of the G20 they're very uh
committed to a strong quarter-based
well-resourced IMF we might we might see
more engagement that comes under their
leadership But ultimately it is the
membership and it is the whole of the
membership not just the G20 all 190
members we need on board thank you so
much crystallina and thank you for
giving us a few extra minutes thanks to
all of you for your patience those of
you who did not get to ask a question
today please come back tomorrow tomorrow
come back tomorrow we have another press
conference we'll try to make sure those
who did not get to ask a question get to
recognize tomorrow thank you all see you
over the next few days bye-bye thank you
very much
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]